i shouldn't say that their first report
is always wrong because that's too
strong
the force first report
is not all the information you're going
to need
when people come up to me freaking out
about something i bet roger got it okay
hey roger that
where'd you see him or you know just
just engage but don't freak out yeah and
if you do this with your family if you
do this with your employees if you do
this with the news if you do this with
your life you're going to be better off
you're not going to be better off you're
going to be more stable you're going to
be more consistent you're going to have
better perspective
it sounds small but it's a real
it's a real thing and it really truly is
beneficial to your life if you do this
yeah
do you think sometimes like people's
immediate reaction like if they
if they jump too quickly right if they
launch too quickly
do you ever think that that is or it
becomes just like a habit for sure it
becomes a habit and it also becomes when
i launch i don't turn back
yeah because i already committed yeah i
launched it i already said disgrace and
when someone says well he was actually
only you know that's a taken out of
context you don't you don't go back and
delete the tweet because then you look
like an idiot right
so instead you just leave it and you say
yeah but even in the context yeah you
take blah blah blah and you just dig in
on stupid stuff so put yourself in
stupid situations don't paint yourself
into a corner all you have to do is
listen read the rest of the articles see
what the other reports say what are you
getting the scoop
what are you a freaking 1957
reporter
trying to get the scoop on the tweet
it's on the post that's good that you
said that right now because the answer
is actually yes i think oh i know it is
because it's like
that's what it seems like i can't read
nobody's mind obviously but that's what
it really feels like when like someone
reposts it and then says disgraceful for
example
it's it is it does seem like they want
to be the one to share it with everyone
and like proclaim some opinion you know
like first you know like almost like as
if because when you consider it this is
just my interpretation again i don't
know but
someone wouldn't really have motivation
to do that
if
it's old news already you know if it's
old news you're not going to like you
know get in the scoop bro it is right
getting the scoop is what is is
definitely a
trigger that makes people do this one of
the one it's not the only one but
there's because some people sometimes
people just overreact because of habit
sometimes they overreact because they
haven't learned this simple lesson that
i'm trying to teach right now yeah it's
a very simple lesson yeah don't
overreact to stuff
it's a very simple lesson and yet people
overreact all the time to all kinds of
stuff
and then also too and this is like
applies to this actually does apply the
news but it applies to someone
breaking news to you like i don't know
your friend
comes running in the room and wants to
proclaim or say this about something
that happened
chances are the chance that of them
exaggerating it are pretty solid they're
very solid yeah why because they're
emotional they're excited about it yeah
they want to tell you they want to tell
you something they want to make sure it
hits you it's hard and all that yeah
well
here's another thing about this
i'm talking about the decision-making
process around this and how this if you
can detach and you can take a grain of
salt with new information
about how it helps you with the
decision-making process
it also will help you remain emotionally
stable
because if you come in yelling hey this
is what's going on and then i get
excited about it my dis my emotions are
skewed which means my decision is my
decision-making process is off but even
in a situation where i don't have a
decision to make
i'm allowing my emotions to go into a
rollercoaster ride for no good freaking
reason which is a dumb move